let's get to the heat advisory in las
vegas and the style stars turning up the
grammy glamour
[Applause]
we're both wearing dolce gabarda so
we're just like
getting some 60s italian vibes at vegas
right now
a house of mamoa like
and they like custom made this for me
and put my album title love socks
i felt so fancy getting a dress design
for me for tonight
this is my bald mane look right here i
wanted to feel like a king i wanted to
look like a king
this is versace i wanted something
simple and i wanted to go edgy with the
hair and have fun dosiacats crystal
encrusted dress took
475 hours to make her accessories a
million dollars in diamonds and a 2 800
glass blown purse that can be used as a
vase filled with what appears to be
werther's original candies by the way
who's your best friend
uh sweetie
this is look number two yeah this is
oscar de la ranca where did you just go
and change how did you do that so fast
in the parking lot i got a big sheet
around me
it's a handbag it's an elizabeth taylor
moment
you know
chrissy teigen's princess gown was made
with 40 yards of taffeta she switched up
her look for the show but kept a pop of
pink feathers travis barker rocked a
fuchsia jacket while the biebs topped
his look with a bright beanie on his
feet 950 balenciaga crocs
that is a grammy winners
jacket that's a grammy winner's job well
i mean honestly that is actually a true
statement we just won our first grammys
i wanted to look like a grammy award i
was just like putting that out into the
universe
another big trend golden girls and guys
hers dundas jumpsuit was inspired by
aretha franklin circa 1976 and carrie
underwood's first of three dresses gave
us bell vibes i just put it on and i
just felt like princess so i was like it
just feels right and i'm gonna roll with
it
a blonde duolippa donned a vintage
versace dress that both cindy crawford
and christy turlington wore in 1992 and
grammy winner scizza didn't let crutches
or a wheelchair keep her from rocking
almost five inch heels turns out she had
a broken ankle i fell out the bed it
sounds foolish i'm clumsy how did you
get up and walk in those hills necessity
gaga had three wardrobe changes but the
highlight of her night aside from
winning this surprise intro from 95 year
old tony bennett who is battling
alzheimer's hi everyone please welcome
lady gaga i'm going to call him right
now
i gotta let him know we won tony's son
accepted on his behalf this is his
favorite category
i feel very blessed to have
sang with a man that has always led with
his heart i love you tony we miss you
another music legend joni mitchell who
received a standing ovation it's been
seven years since she suffered a brain
aneurysm harry styles who is a massive
fan titled his upcoming album after her
song harry's house we caught up with
joni earlier as she was named the music
cares person of the year harry styles
i'm wondering like if there could ever
be a chance that maybe you guys could
record together it could be yeah we have
these jams at my house from time to time
you know maybe he'll show up at one of
them
meanwhile in l.a only e.t was at stephen
tyler's grammy watch party which was
tame by his standards what's the wildest
grammys experience over the years with
aerosmith i can't tell you that
absolutely not i'll just get in trouble
but it has to do with that
[Music]
you